ich denke Deutschland muss
gesellschaftlich kaltstartfähig werdende
Gesellschaft lebt vom Zusammenhalt von
der Solidarität von der Integration über
die verschiedenen Menschen Weg über die
verschiedenen Generationen hinweg und
wir leben in einer Zeit die immer
unsicherer wird das haben wir heute auch
diskutiert wo Hybride Bedrohungen unsere
Gesellschaft bedrohen wir haben denen
die Globalisierung wir haben den
demografischen Wandel wir haben die
Transformation also alles Dinge die die
Gesellschaft rasend schnell verändern
und der Staat musste die
Rahmenbedingungen bieten um diesen
Wandel mit zu gestalten und ich glaube
dass wir enger zusammenrücken können
dazu brauchen wir auch etwas Eigenes und
das könnte ein allgemeiner
gemeinschaftsdienst sein für alle Jungen
und Mädchen für alle jungen Menschen in
unserem Land unabhängig von der
Staatsbürgerschaft da könnte vielleicht
6 9 oder 12 Monate dauern freie
Wahlmöglichkeiten Entwicklungshilfe über
die Pflege übers Krankenhaus bisschen zu
Streitkräften und damit denke ich
könnten wir für mehr Integration sorgen
auch für mehr Durchmischung sorgen
zwischen den Landesteilen und dafür das
gesellschaftlich wertvolle Aufgaben
wirklich wahrgenommen werden ich glaube
es könnte uns sehr sehr viel helfen und
das interessante ich frage jede Klasse
die mich im Bundestag besucht danach wie
findet ihr das ohne es vor mit ihm zu
diskutieren ein Jahr für dein Land so
ganz provokativ und aus meinem Wahlkreis
wieder ich kann wieder nur meinen
kleinen Vorgarten betrachten da sagen 65
bis 75% der Schüler in den Klassen
jeweils möchten wir möchten wir machen
aber dann doch wenige denn wir stellen
fest wenige gehen dann freiwillig zur
Bundeswehr oder machen ein freiwilliges
soziales Jahr sie sind Bundeswehr
Offizier was hat Ihnen diese Zeit
gelernt ich bin selber als Wehrpflicht
Gegner zur Bundeswehr gekommen 2003 und
mein Vater hat mich damals überredet
mein Wehrdienst zu machen das habe ich
gesehen habe gesehen da wird ein Mensch
noch akzeptiert ich war damals schon
politisch aktiv und bin gleich an meinem
ersten Tag für eine politische Aktivität
sogar freigestellt worden abends zwei
drei Stunden weil eben der ganze Mensch
zählt und ich glaube manchmal ist auch
wichtig so eine kleine Schubs zu kriegen
zu Orientierung ich finde wichtig dass
man auswählen kann dass man nicht zur
Bundeswehr muss und sagen muss
Bundeswehr oder Zivildienst sondern das
ist eine breiteres Angebot ist was junge
Menschen auch als motivierend empfinden
und das kann glaube ich sehr viel dazu
beitragen die gesellschaftlichen
Probleme zu lösen oder kleiner zu machen
Zara glaubst du dass so ein Ja oder
vielleicht auch nur sechs Monate wie
Herr altersvorschlagen würde dann
tatsächlich von den Jugendlichen auch so
begeistert aufgenommen wird wie sie es
ihm von Angesicht zu Angesicht auch
sagen wahrscheinlich wenn die nicht so
begeistert ja ja aber das ist nicht alle
ja aber vielleicht muss das sein
tatsächlich also ich stimme ihm sehr zu
ich sehe das genauso wie er sich
tatsächlich dass wir sowas brauchen also
so ein soziales ja was aber viel breiter
aufgebaut ist wo man sich nicht
entscheiden muss und wo man wo die Leute
sehr sozial sich engagieren können viel
lernen auch für ihr Leben auch geprägt
werden und ich glaube ehrlich gesagt das
ist unser Gesetz unserer Gesellschaft
fehlt gerade wenn man auch merkt ähm wie
die Gesellschaft sich gespaltet
auseinander trifft auch schon in
jugendaltern auch wenn wir sehen dass
Jugendkriminalität und
Kinderkriminalität steigt also ich
glaube gesellschaftlich müssen wir viel
mehr sozial machen und da kann sowas
schon ein großer Beitrag sein gerade
auch wichtigen Punkt wo sie sagen für
ein Land also auch dieses Gefühl dass
ich etwas für mein Land tue das ist mir
ziemlich verloren gegangen das merke ich
auch in meiner Generation dass man gar
nicht mehr sagt ich tue das für mein
Land gerne und das ist ein ganz anderes
Gefühl was was da auch entstehen könnte
wir sehen ja auch in der Ukraine was
eben eine Gesellschaft bewältigen kann
also eine quasi unlösbare Aufgabe wenn
sie zusammen steht und vielleicht wenn
wir in diese Richtung so ein bisschen
kommen dass wir wieder mehr zusammen
stehen dann kriegen mit unserem Land
auch viel viel mehr geschafft haben wir
vielleicht viel viel mehr veränderungs
Zuversicht ne das ist auch noch mal wenn
ich das nochmal ganz gut das ist auch
unter dem Gesichtspunkte interessant
dass wir sagen wir leben ja kommunikativ
und überhaupt leben wir in verschiedenen
Blasen wir leben immer stärker in Filter
Blasen also das ist in den sozialen
Medien die immer wichtiger geworden sind
und die immer stärker das Leben kriegen
auch gerade der jüngeren ist ja der Fall
dass man nur noch mit Gleichgesinnten
spricht und man kann gar nicht mehr mit
Leuten sprechen die eine ganz andere
Meinung haben die die Fähigkeit ist ja
nicht angeboren die muss man lernen das
kann man nicht mehr und das ist wiederum
schwierig für die Demokratie weil
demokratie heißt ja jeder muss mit jedem
reden können eigentlich und politische
Probleme bereden können und Kompromisse
schließen können mit jedem das muss man
aber üben und wenn wir das nicht mehr
automatisch üben durch Schule und so
weiter gibt ja auch dann wieder mehr
Privatschule und so weiter wird auch
getrennt das ist das was sie gesagt alle
Teile der Gesellschaft durchmischen
durchmischen sich stärker das wäre diese
das wäre ganz großer
fanssen sind auch Familienvater würden
Sie zustimmen ne dass ihre Kinder so
etwas machen einen gemeinschaftsjahr ein
paar gemeinschaftsmonate oder dann eben
doch zur Bundeswehr meine Tochter macht
so eine Art freiwilliges kulturelles
Jahr gerade
ich weiß was auf was was sie abziehen
und das stimmt auch irgendwo diese die
Identifikation mit der Gesellschaft ich
habe nur ein Problem mit Zwang ja wir
bauen immer mehr Zwänge auf ja vom jetzt
bin ich wieder bei meinem Thema Zwang
und so weiter es ist es ist mir zu viel
Zwang ich halte die Idee gut ich halte
Angebote gut aber sie wissen finde ich
freiwillig sein und ich habe ein großes
Problem wenn man quasi auf dem Rücken
von jungen Leuten
andere Probleme lösen willst wie zum
Beispiel dem pflegemangel das ist eine
riesen Versäumnis der Politik der
letzten 20 Jahre dann billig den Zivi
das halte ich überhaupt für keine gute
Idee aber grundsätzlich dass man
Jugendlichen die auch viel zu früh zum
Beispiel heute Abitur machen also
17-Jährige Abiturienten das ist wirklich
die sind die sind nicht reif für auch
für ein Studium ja und ich denke dass
man ihn ein Angebot macht finde ich
wirklich sehr gut aber ich habe einfach
jetzt ich glaube wir müssen mal von
zwingen etwas Abstand bekommen in dieser
Gesellschaft wurden sie abgezockt oder
reingelegt das ist also eine
Verzehnfachung es kann nicht wahr sein
jetzt melden unsere Reporter kümmern
sich um Ihren Fall
kämpft für Sie